have to
see it again
the ball did not hit the rim so the shot
clock is correct at nine seconds see you
had i could have told you yeah
that's what they need to do is start
looking over here and
you know you and i can help them the
heck with all that review there here we
go pacers do have a foul to give if they
want paul rises up for three hit the
side of the backboard now curry
and no good and it's craig
into the hands of sykes and a foul on
sykes oh man the warriors a number of
great looks
and they come up empty on this side of
the floor
11.4 left sikes
has a chance to extend the lead
well the warriors can get up here under
pressure right now going to get gary
payton a second into the game
rick carlisle is going to take a time
out to advance the ball
but you've got to be able to get the
ball in
here first and foremost worry about the
free throws later inbounding against
pressure
or the inability to inbound against
pressure can decide a lot of games here
down the stretch
golden state
and this was better
the finish was oh
so now we're tied at 106.
warriors took the lead at the free throw
line it's 110 106. what you're doing now
tied at 110 just in holidays that's a
really bad play by stealth yeah that's
right still golden state's got a chance
here chuckster want to scott away dunk
it dunk it lay it in
it's called i mean like oh you gotta lay
that you got to make that i would have
tried to dunk it oh golden state scored
the first five points over time and then
indiana took over duarte there see this
right here you're not expecting i know
he oh so how many
when you're giving away you have 21
turnovers
against these guys they're not a great
defensive team with these guys they
playing with well that's good right
there that's good right here
the golden state warriors
lose this one 121-117
in overtime as the indiana pacers
playing on back-to-back nights they got
so lucky on that play right there
because if clay get that ball he's going
to be pulling it all by himself
how about jeremy lamb chico
please oh please
indiana had been on 19 when trailing at
the half until last night when they won
a game when they trailed at the half and
tonight they did it again
and they take it one last stevenson
effect what did they beat last night
lakers
they went undefeated in california yes
how about that that's pretty impressive
with those guys they got yeah uh so one
they win it by four uh duarte goes for
27. uh steph goes for 39 on the night
goes 12 out of 27
6 out of 16 from deep his third his 14th
game of at least 30 points
his eighth game of at least 35 the most
in the nba you know when i was telling i
was what i said last week and all these
like guys who act like that just because
you get paid to know basketball don't
mean you know anything about basketball
they're like oh this is going to be
great when they get clay back when they
get clay back everything's going to be
smooth obviously i know draymond out but
i said the two guys i'm gonna be
watching
the two guys he was gonna have the most
effect upon was wiggins
and pool and pool
and wiggins
is five for 15 on the head 11
and pooh has only got four ushers
on one i don't know if those guys are
the type of guys who are going to do
dirty work
like i know it's easy to say
and then people say well they got the
championship degree those guys don't
have championship degrees wiggins is off
wiggins is an offensive player
pool is an offensive player
now you're not getting shots and i have
played with guys i have played with guys
if they don't get involved offensively
it's hard for them to get murdered
because because earner defense is the
hardest part of the game chuck the man
got 15 shots he just got to play better
wiggles got 15 shots that's good for him
i know but he hasn't played well since
clay came back well
you got to look in the mirror
jack everybody you know you always
assume like it's hard for a guy who's an
offensive player
i think that 15 years old but i'm saying
he's in a slop right now because like i
said he's gonna have to make the
adjustment
he to me he got to make the biggest
adjustment
out of all the guys and then pool also